It was a night of celebrations for supporters
of France's new centrist party,
La republic en Marche - Republic on the move.
"My dear fellow citizens, France is back.
For a month the President of the Republic
has embodied confidence, will, and boldness,
in France as well as on the international
stage.
The government on his side illustrates, through
its composition, a completely new grouping,
and it is determined to serve France and to
respond to the French people's expectations."
Pollsters predict that the party could win
400 or more seats out of 577 in Parliament,
after next Sunday's second round.
A majority that will be crucial to push through
controversial reforms to work and pensions.
But voter turnout was at a record low on Sunday
- and opponents from both sides of the political
spectrum say that means President Macron doesn't
have the mandate to carry out those reforms.
Far right Front National leader Marine Le
Pen called on citizens to use their votes
to stop Macron's plans.
"We need some real members
of parliament who will oppose the catastrophic
policies Emmanuel Macron is preparing.
He is about to commit a slaughter of
labour laws that will send millions of workers
into instability without bringing anything
to companies."
There's also concern that a huge parliamentary
majority for La Republic En Marche would leave
little room for debate - as far left leader
Jean Luc Melenchon warned:
"In the second round, do not give and don't allow anyone to give total power to the president's party."
Politicians are now racing to get people to
the polls for next Sunday's run off.